à moins d'un mois et demi du festival de
loire le niveau du fleuve est inférieur
d'un mètre par rapport à sa coque normal
comme en 2003 si la situation n'est pas
encore critique pour permettre aux
bateaux de naviguer il ne faudrait pas
que le niveau continue à baisser
inquiet non pas vraiment pour le
festival on est encore à un mois un mois
et demi du festival par contre pour la
navigation actuelle en considérant qu'
on va encore perdre des quelques
centimètres bon ça favorise pas la
navigation on est obligé donc de limiter
un peu le les promenades sur bateau
parce qu'on ne peut pas aller dans
toutes les zones actuellement pour les
mariniers qui connaissent les passages
il est possible de naviguer entre les
bancs de sable et les pierres des
anciens digue de plus en plus visible
orléans on n'a pas beaucoup de fond au
yoyo entre les bancs de sable
par exemple le là on voit le banc de
sable qui est végétalisée on voit
quelques touffes d'herbe et toute la
partie qui est après elle est arrivée
cet hiver les bancs de sable il
progresse jusqu'à 500 m par an donc
petit à petit gagne sur cette partie de
petit thouars l'année dernière on
passait là dans la brèche et on pouvait
aller jusqu'aux pour cette année c'est
fermé donc là on le voit très bien on
arrive là avec plus que aller là il ya
25 cm d'eau là le problème c'est qu'on
est juste dans laxe du chenal d'amener
delécluse donc pour les bateaux qui
auraient besoin de sortir s'ils ont un
grand tirant d'eau là ça passe plus donc
là ça c'est une problématique de ce
sable à qui revient le festival de loire
qui doit avoir lieu du 23 au 27
septembre prochain accueillera cette
année plus de 200 bateaux de loire est
d'ailleurs 700 mariniers 450 artistes et
une centaine d'exposants et devrait
attirer quelque 650 mille visiteurs